hello my name is Council Robin Dre and
I'm chairman of Rockford district
council I would like to personally thank
you all for your effort you have made to
ensure that our community stay safe and
the support that I have seen residents
given each other during these times is
enormous ly important that we work
together and stay at home to help the
NHS and to save lives I am so pleased to
see so many of our residents supporting
our health care service in a weekly clap
for the NHS that I myself have also been
proudly taking part in our frontline
workers are carrying us through this
pandemic although we have United as a
community I know there are people out
there who may be isolated or have no
friends and family close by if you find
yourself in this situation please get in
touch with the Rockford district
community response up helpline on zero
one two six eight seven seven double
nine double nine the team of volunteers
are taking calls between 9 a.m. and 4
p.m. seven days a week and to date have
taken over 300 calls from residents who
are struggling please be assured that
you are not alone I am immensely proud
about everyone in our district and I
encourage all of our residents to keep
up the good work thank you